We're gonna kick it off by tackling a topic
that I am truly fascinated with.
And it's dating.
Because I am convinced that no matter what in life
you are contending, and wrestling with,
and finessing, and working through, a relationship.
I don't care who it's with,
you're in a relationship with something.
It could be your dog, your grandmother, your sister,
your mother, your brother, your best friend,
your husband, your wife.
We're all trying to figure out a or multiple relationships.
And when it comes to dating,
I feel that behavior is really become
my number one thing that I like to dissect and discuss.
So is anyone here dating situation,
anyone dating in the wall?
Marina?
Hi Marina.
So I am in a long distance relationship.
My boyfriend lives in England and I live in Florida.
It's incredibly difficult.
Not only the time difference,
the time that we've been apart.
And we have no idea when we're gonna see each other next.
How long have you been dating?
We have been together for about a year.
And what is your end game?
I mean, we've talked about a life together.
It's incredibly, you know, difficult,
especially right now 'cause we just have
no clue what's going on.
Also, we're kind of in a challenging profession.
We both, we met working on a cruise ship,
so we both work on cruise ships.
With our contract lengths, and you know,
sometimes I'm on one side of the world
and he's on the other side of the world.
And so that makes it even more challenging.
Okay, so maybe when your industry resumes,
life resumes for all of us.
So right now you are in a purgatory that you cannot control.
Here is the good news, is usually in normal times
I'm like, long distance, great, it'll last that much longer
because when you're in each other's faces 24/7,
it's not good.
That said, when you wanna build a life with someone,
I believe down the road, concessions, and you know,
geography, and things will have to get sorted out.
But since none of that is within your control right now,
make this the most romantic time.
Write letters, find new ways of communicating,
learn more about each other in inventive,
sexy, cool, fun ways.
Say, we're gonna make this time count
in a way it never could've otherwise.
And then when things go back to a different kind of normal,
we'll figure out what we can do then
and take each step as it comes.
But for now I say, go for it,
and figure out every single new, unique way
that you two can stay connected
and learn more about each other.
Yeah, you don't like that advice.
I love that, thank you so much.
Oh good, oh good, phew.
Literally, find games that you can play,
like join Words With Friends
and become Scrabble buddies online.
Write love letters to each other, send care packages.
Show each other, say, I want you to watch
this movie tonight, and then tomorrow we'll discuss
'cause it's one of my favorite,
and I can't wait to see what you think.
Get clever.
I love it, thank you so much.
And then you can say, and when I do see you,
you better watch out 'cause I'm going and attacking you.
(audience clapping)
A little dangle of a promise
and a romantic like finish is so fun.
Okay.
So that was so fun.
(upbeat music)